bonjour je suis très bo j'ai dix ans je
suis le frère le grand frère de et ses
balles c'était dur au début je veux
j'avais je me soucie un peu et après je
me suis un petit peu habitué mais
j'aurais préféré qu'ils ne le soient pas
quoi j'essaye de le faire jouer
d'attirer son attention
ça me rend triste de voir qu'il peut pas
faire les mêmes choses qu'eux d'où il
comprend pas ce qu'on essaye de lui
faire faire il ne comprend pas tout ça
parce qu'on a dit ça sert de baptiste
comme une insulte
ben je sais pas peut-être que dans mon
dos il y en a qui se moque il faut pas
baisser les bras même si c'est compliqué
il faut garder son calme et les cils
vivre avec comme on peut et quand peu